hi there i haven't stopped learning
languages i finished my 90-day challenge
um
where i was focusing on learning korean
and uploading videos every day
and for the last little while i've been
doing other things
and in particular i've been starting to
spend more and more time on ukrainian
because i'm following the events in
ukraine i'm watching various ukrainian
television stations
and television programs some of the
discussions are in russian a lot are in
ukrainian so i want to be able to
understand more and more of it so what
i've done is i've got a link and i'm
using the
hebrew slot because i have no immediate
plans to learn hebrew
and there's no way that a ukrainian word
could be confused for a
hebrew word so that i won't be messing
up
uh
you know the hints that we cast in other
words if i were to save words it might
show up for someone else who's learning
that language but hebrew and ukrainian
they're not going to be confused because
it's a completely different writing
system
and so i just grab articles from various
ukrainian
news sites
import them in the link
click on the words that i need
uh go to google translate
google translate has this detect
language function so very quickly it
detects that it's ukrainian i get my
meaning i type it in so i'm building up
more and more
yellow words so whereas when i started
you know it was a solid blue
new words to me now there's a lot of
white words because after a while i get
to know what these words mean or
versions or variations of these words
and of course i'm converting a lot to
yellow
i'm understanding more and more of it
it's the process actually going quite
quickly i would say
almost more quickly than roma more
quickly than romanian certainly more
quickly than
korean
and so then i'm listening to these
interviews in ukrainian i'm
understanding more and more of it i
think if i keep at it
you know it won't take me very long
before i'll be understanding
what these people are saying i've no
immediate plans to speak ukrainian i
have no need to speak ukrainian although
again
as i've always said if i have a
high you know level of understanding and
vocabulary i could learn to speak very
quickly and once i have had that amount
of the language sort of in me if i were
to review some of the basic grammar
rules of ukrainian apparently they have
evocative case and some of the
declensions you know our conjugation
endings are a little different some
other things i'm sure there are other
things that are different from russian
i'll find those off i'll find those out
afterwards but i don't need that kind of
detail in order to understand what i'm
reading and listening to
and of course
you know uh i was at uh my japanese
restaurant for lunch where there are
koreans in the kitchen there that i
talked to
it's sort of like an open kitchen
and so yeah i spoke a bit of korean
there and i'm gonna get back to korea
and i'm continuing to have transcripts
made of kim jung-ha's podcast but right
now the focus is on the situation in
ukraine and not only is my ukrainian
improving but my russian is is
improving more and more because when i
hear russian now after listening to
ukrainian which i kind of foggy
understand the russian is crystal clear
so that i'm improving in both those
languages and now i feel if i do a month
or so of ukrainian
i think i'll do the same with polish
just go in there and start reading
websites in
polish find some polish uh tv programs
start following events in poland and it
won't take me very long to get the
polish up to a level where at least i
can understand
so right now um yeah i'm pursuing my uh
my slavic language kick and it's so
important i believe to be interested if
you have this this right now i'm very
interested in the events in ukraine in
following them and in hearing the
different perspectives the different
politicians and the ones from the east
of course speak russian the ones from
the west speak ukrainian even the
politicians from the east will also
speak ukrainian so i hear the same
people speaking in two languages
sometimes i mean it's all very
interesting i guess the
the pleasure of being a polyglot is that
you can
sort of access all of this information
in the language and that you can start
learning a new language if you have
another language already which is very
similar to that language
the trouble is finding the time to do
all these things because i really would
like to go back and do more with my
korean because i got a great big head of
steam going behind my korean but i'll go
back to it just as i will go back to my
check
just as i uh you know can go back to
russian and constantly continue to
improve in these languages
so i mean ukrainian uh korean uh i'll be
i'll be using these languages in
different ways accessing different
sources of information for many many
years
so
it's a lot of fun i'm enjoying it and
it's a sunny day